the reviews are in and mobius sony super
vampire movie seems to kind of suck what
else can i do
more bs just hit theaters and reviewers
have already started sinking their teeth
into it over on rotten tomatoes the
internet's leading film review site
people have been ripping the marvel
comics inspired superhero flick to
shreds saying mobius is boring and
inconsistent pretty much across the
board a negative sentiment echoes the
early impressions about the jared leto
lead project which also styles former
doctor who actor matt smith as well as
adria arjuna jared harris al madrigal
and tyrese gibson as collider sab astley
previously said on twitter
mobius is about as bad as you were
expecting a 2005 pluck collides with
visually confusing cgi to create a bit
of a snoozefest featuring some of the
worst post-credits scenes you've ever
seen sony are off their rocker other
early reviews called morbius a number of
different things few of them flattering
with some assessing it as disjointed and
messy based on the early reactions it
was pretty clear that the critiques on
rotten tomatoes probably wouldn't be
pretty here's what reviewers are saying
about mobius
just accept who you are
the bad guy
there's really no way around it the vast
majority of critics on rotten tomatoes
dislike mobius in fact it would be an
understatement to say they merely
dislike it from the looks of it
reviewers seem to consider morbius one
of those rare movies that is such a
failure the only difference between
reviews involves the words to describe
how bad it is for example barry hurts of
the globe and mail states that the movie
is so very bad that it might actually
end up single-handedly tanking the
superhero movie trend he wrote if there
is any justice in hollywood morbius will
be retconned to the margins of superhero
cinema history if the film doesn't bury
the genre alive first that is robbie
colin of the telegraph didn't hide his
thoughts about the movie's pointlessness
writing it goes on for about an hour and
45 minutes and right up until the second
it ends you keep feeling as if it's just
about to start other critics turn their
ayah towards sony calling morbius an
obvious example of a cynical
money-making machine
charlotte o'sullivan of london evening
standard called it a cash grab so sloppy
it makes you wonder if the top brass of
sony are nihilistic members of the
undead meanwhile others chose to slouch
into the vampire buns like brian lloyd
of entertainment ie who wrote
morbius really does
suck yes we couldn't even come up with
something more inventive folks
to be fair neither could we how far are
we allowed to go
to fix something that's broken
it's not just the movie's general
quality that's drawing the reviewers
ayah several critics have also pointed
out that jared leto who as an academy
award winner clearly has a history of
knowing how to act doesn't quite manage
to impress as a titular character for
various reasons
according to megan navarro of bloody
disgusting letto simply fails to
captivate in the same way as tom hardy
does in his symbiote-filled corner of
sony's universe of marvel characters she
wrote without say someone like tom hardy
embracing the weirdness of the character
in venom it's tough to find rooting
interest or muster any excitement with
the vampiric batman meanwhile stephanie
zakharik of time felt that while leto
does bring an element of emotion in the
movie he perhaps isn't so much a serious
actor as one who takes himself very
seriously
nobody has ever said that to me nobody
michael phillips of the chicago tribune
stepped back to look at the bigger
picture and found that when you combine
mobius with leto's recent turn as paulo
gucci and house of gucci it can be very
difficult to comprehend the actor's ways
the critic wrote i don't relish pinning
blame or a tail or horns or anything on
a particular star but my bafflement
regarding leto is becoming chronic and
i'm still recovering from his opera
buffer turn and chico mark's dialect in
house of gucci all in all whether
audiences find the movie enjoyable or
not it's already pretty clear that the
critics don't like mobius and they don't
think you will either check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
movies and tv shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one